hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive over the next half an
hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the daily mirror
columnist suzy boniface
and the conservative commentator tim
montgomery so a very good evening to
both of you
hello so let's take a look first at
what's making the front pages and the
financial times leads with the
former scottish first minister alex
salmond re-emergent onto the political
stage
with the formation of his new alba party
the telegraph reports that starting in
september people over the age of 70 will
be given
a third covert 19 jab to boost their
immunity
according to the eye the manufacture of
the vaccine has led to
a number of scientific discoveries which
will bring about massive changes in how
other viruses as well as cancer diabetes
and cystic fibrosis
are treated the times here is that in an
effort to stimulate spending the
government will allow
high street shops to stay open until 10
pm once lockdown is loosened
pm our first taste of freedom but be
safe
is the headline in the express the
mirror understands the duchess of
cambridge has written a personal letter
of condolence to the family of sarah
everard
who was found dead after she went
missing in south london three weeks ago
thousands of call center staff could be
monitored while they work from home
including monitoring whether they're
eating or looking at their phones or
leaving their desk that's according to
the guardian
and the star reports on a plan to move
the container ship blocking the suez
canal
using the power of the mind
that's one theory i hadn't seen um susie
boniface tim montgomery here with me
tonight to go through
some of those front pages and see lots
of different stories actually
around tonight but you've picked out the
financial times and i'm sure this story
will pop
up in the papers somewhere in all the
papers and this
is the announcement today by alex salmon
that he's launching a new political
party in scotland
was that a big surprise
uh depends really um let's take this
dispassionately so if you think that the
you know there's a reason for alex
salmond and a new political party
if you believe that there is an infinite
number of potential
independence votes in scotland and that
alex salmond himself
can draw them out of people who would
otherwise be swing voters
there is no point to it and it's merely
to splitting the vote if you think he is
so unpopular north of the border that
it's not going to work he's just going
to split the existing
finite independence vote two different
ways and it's worth bearing in mind
that alex salmon's current popularity
rating in scotland is
approaching that of boris johnson's it's
pretty low it's -44
the last one i saw um boris johnson's
about minus 50.
so the fact that alex salmond thinks he
could be able to lead
a new political movement of some kind up
against
the long-established snp with long
established independence nationalist
credentials is laughable really this is
one man's ego a psychodrama that he's
got
going on with nicola sturgeon he's
decided
firstly that she should have intervened
in inquiries
into whether or not he was sexually
harassed women secondly that
she was no longer fit for office because
of the way she had refused to intervene
then that got overruled and she is still
fit for office apparently
and now he's launching a party which is
going to only split her vote
potentially mean that the smp need to
get rid of her because he's going to
cause more problems for her
it's it's one man's egotistical
desperate need
for attention and publicity it's not
going to achieve
anything very much for the scottish
independence movement
and then i can't remember who it was tim
probably remembers the person who said
that um
you know a period of silence from you
would be welcome
alex sandler really needs to shut up and
sit down for a bit until everyone's
forgotten what an absolute
piece of work he's been okay well well
certainly his political rivals have
talked about it being a vanity project
and yet while his
personal polling isn't great tim
he is a big and um
very affluent unlike me getting the
sentence out
and powerful political figure isn't he
and he would say
that this is a bid for a super majority
for independence he said he's not out to
rival the snp he's out to compliment it
well there are complicated uh reasons
why because of the australia and
scottish voting
system and there may be benefits to
independence through having an extra
party
but i think that's going to be
considerably outweighed by the simple
fact and i think we all know why alex
salmond has launched this party
he's still got this huge grudge against
nicola
sturgeon and i think there is a real
danger for the snp for the nationalist
cause
that this continuing psychodrama between
salmon and sturgeon
will become quite a significant part of
the campaign
and so the snp won't be talking about
what they want to their vision for
scotland
they'll be talking like you know sort of
a tip attack argument between
the two former leaders of the snp so
it's hard
it's a a surprise for all of us that
this happened today
but i can't think it would be overall
good for
nicola sturgeon in the independence
movement well yes and it
does get us all talking about the issue
of scottish independence
again doesn't it susie and within this
article in the financial times
uh some people talking about whether or
not a vote should be allowed to happen
yeah um john major has written in the
paper about the fact there should be if
scotland
is going to be um determinedly wanting
to have a vote on this and they should
be allowed to do so
um the movement for independence has had
a massive boost basically in the past
year the graphs have all gone
straight up because of boris johnson's
handling of the pandemic compared to
nicola sturgeons mostly um and so he
says you know
they're going to have to have a vote if
they if they really really want one and
then he argues that you know fact and
reason
will he is sure within the day for
staying in the union
um but that's exactly the the plan that
he had for the eu referendum look how
that turned out
tim what do you make of that well when
david cameron was leader and
john major was really almost the
unofficial spokesman
um for the prime minister when david
cameron had a message that he wanted to
go out there ahead of when he was
willing to say it he used
john major the relationship between john
major and boris johnson is completely
different it's not a happy relationship
so
this is very much john major freelancing
i think there is
a divine a division in number 10 as to
whether they should grant
a referendum or not but i think quite
rightly at the moment the whole focus of
downing street
is on the run-up to the the
parliamentary elections in scotland
because if
we can deny and they can deny the
unionist parties can deny
um the uh nationalists um a majority
then it's a moot question and i think
there is every possibility now partly
because of the salmon candidacy
partly because of the divisions in the
snp after the whole business with that
we've been
going through over the last few weeks
there's every possibility of denying um
uh the snp majority oh well be
fascinating to see
um let's move on to a couple of um
covert 19 related stories that have made
the front pages
different angles the daily telegraph
first of all their headline is
over 70 is to get booster jabs from
september
um is this a big surprise suzy i mean we
we understand that the government says
that we're going to
hit those targets that it's set for
everyone to get two
doses of the vaccine but they're talking
about a third booster jabs aren't they
here
yeah uh and to be frank i've read this
story i think it must be a dozen times
in different newspapers in the course of
the past
a few months but basically they're
saying that there will be some kind of
booster jab
after all adults have been offered their
first vaccine over the course of the
summer
the interesting bit though is buried in
the story in which it says that uh
nadeem zahari the vaccines minister says
that
professor jonathan van tam who is
considered very reliable in terms of his
information handling this stuff
believes there will be a september
requirement
for a booster which is code for saying
there's going to be a september wave
is that how you interpret it tim as well
i think there is certainly a lot of the
people that are
involved in the fight against kobe of
course they have to
emphasize this because that's their sole
focus
the government of course has to focus on
education the other health effects of
lockdown
and so i think then they will listen to
people like jonathan van tan
but um i don't think that that is
uppermost in the government's mind
or is the uppermost um probability and
you know the numbers that struck me from
the telegraph
piece and you know just looking at them
now you know the uk's latest um
you know number of infections is 6 000.
france is 42
000 and germany is 21 000 and
yes britain had a very poor start to
this crisis relatively
but fortunately because of the vaccine
revolution
we're in a much better position and long
may that continue
indeed everyone hopes that it does
continue to go in the right direction
you're right and let's
have a look at the eyes angle tomorrow
susie
they are talking about some some of the
uh
scientific lessons that have been
learned from this aren't they the the
uh the vaccine revolution they're
calling it and saying that it could have
all sorts of positives for other areas
of medicine
yeah um and as someone who got her
vaccine yesterday
because congratulations got me on the
part
um i i would say hooray but what it
basically saying here is that the
technological
advancement that happened in a very
short space of time and
for those of us or the viewers who have
been suspicious of that
it's not because it happened in a short
space of time that's the concern here
it's the fact that because there is a
pandemic and a deadly disease that was
affecting the global north and the
richest nations in the world
those governments and those
pharmaceutical companies through the
kitchen sink asset
we had some of this tech coming along in
development but it happened very very
quick
and because there was a pandemic it
could be tested on
twenty thousand people very very quickly
which of course
other diseases you've gotta wait a long
time before you can have trials on
twenty thousand people
with a vaccine so what you've got here
is uh some amazing environment sponsors
that have happened very very quickly
because of the
terrible situation we found ourselves in
and they think now they're going to be
able to use that same kind of
portmanteau of using
a denatured virus or using a way that
they can
program the rna in your immune system
not the dna your genetic code does not
get altered the messenger rna
to go and tackle other problems and you
know there are lots of things in our
bodies that go wrong because there's a
way that the cell is communicating its
function
using its rna it comes out wrong whether
that's diabetes whether it's epilepsy
whether it's heart disease
whether it's cancers and if they can fix
that the way that the
the cells actually communicate and
perform their function with one little
jab
then you know perhaps the world's our
oyster
well yeah certainly would be very
hopeful wouldn't it and we're going to
take a break right there though
lots to talk about though very shortly
including what impact does
video calling have on teamwork
technology permitting we're going to be
discussing that in a moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our job is to tell the truth this is a
forgotten front line
they are dying here
boys we've got some interesting ways of
showing you what's going on their
message to us
get ready instructing you to stay at
home
i can't believe we did that it's pretty
special isn't it should protect our
heritage unfortunately it will become
part of azerbaijan
this monastery is under the protection
for now the next five years at least of
russian peacekeepers
i'm dinah magni and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
i witnessed the despair of the armenians
in nagorno-karabakh who were digging up
the soil of their dead relatives
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
despite what their strategy is i'm not
sure but they have made
some arrests already today
they can't kill everyone they can't
shoot everyone
they can't arrest everybody
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
i mean this clearly says i love hitler
are you saying that
doesn't say hitler
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
russia insists that its military buildup
in the arctic is purely defensive
[Music]
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertaining
podcast
but wherever you are welcome to the
safety ridge
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all that politics podcast
for the
listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free welcome back you're watching
the press preview with me tonight
susie boniface and tim montgomery and
tim we're turning to the front page of
the times next and
their lead story says that high street
shops are going to open until
10 p.m once restrictions are lifted
good idea i don't know um
last time that uh the uh
lockdowns were ending the first time and
ricky soon at the chancellor wanted us
to
shop on sundays but that was resisted by
tory mps quite rightly i think them shot
workers that deserve at least one day
off and so now i think he's trying to
know that he can't get
sunday trading through parliament he's
looking to extend shopping hours
into the evening and i'm not sure that's
going to be
a huge enthusiastic thing for most
people to shop late at night although
the weather's going to be a little bit
better so it might be
um okay but of course then we link to
the suez
story you know will we actually have the
goods in the shops to
to buy but reaches recently it's clearly
trying to take advantage of what we saw
in china
after it's locked down ended something
called revenge consumerism
where really shops were emptied by
chinese consumers
who just wanted to go out and spend
money and then as chancellor is hoping
the same happens in britain
yeah interesting isn't it susie i mean i
know we're all a bit bored of our own
front rooms but do we all want to go
shopping at 10 o'clock at night i love
the little sub head it says go have fun
chancellor tells public um you know but
maybe
maybe people be really relieved to be
back in the shop
i'd love to go and have some fun if only
the government had actually given me any
help as a self-employed person during
the past year pandemic they haven't
unfortunately
there are seven in eight people in this
country that are counting the pennies
after the pandemic one in eight has
savings and doesn't mind
that one in eight might go out and spend
at ten o'clock in the evening
but uh they'll be lucky if they can find
a shop still opening the high street of
course
um and one in eight people isn't gonna
keep that keep the economy going he's
there's
if he was an inventive decent chancellor
he'd be finding a way to deal with the
new economy we've got
not try to restart the one we had and
which failed
okay and i quickly want to squeeze in
another story in the times and the
headline is video calls don't improve
teamworking which is interesting to
discuss in our current
format uh via kind of video conferencing
really tim what do you think
well i shouldn't say this on sky
newshour so i apologize but
i'm nervous now go on i'm much more of a
radio person
generally anyway and this um this survey
that uh the times is quoting
says you know put some people in a audio
only set up and in
other people in a video set up and
actually people
in the audio setup cooperated more
productively
and um so despite the fact that we've
all been on these video calls over the
last uh
few uh over the last year it may well be
that actually audio
works better so rude tim really
while we're on the telly i will forgive
you though i will forgive you
i've been using video calling to teach
students
over zoom and i'm doing it from an area
that's got really poor broadband
coverage so the fact that the cameras
don't always work
has caused real problems because we
don't have a government that's
subsidized proper fiber
roll out across the country um but i
like having to look at people's
backgrounds and seeing what they've got
on their walls and i'm
worried about tim's very bare cell that
he seems to have been locked in there
with some sticks
but you know i i like having some extra
detail
i want you focused on the stuff not on
my backdrop
oh you've got too much butter in your
backdrop
this is a journalist working journalist
desk tim
i can have to break it off
we've got background wars going on oh
i'm nervous when you hold things off i
don't know what it's going to say anyway
we are out of time
susie and tim good to see you both um
i'll see you again at 11 30 i'm pleased
to say see you then
and before we go if you've missed any of
the press preview tonight it will be
available shortly and every night on
our youtube channel meanwhile coming up
next on sky news at 11
sky news reveals evidence of mass rape
by soldiers
in the war in ethiopia that coming up
and all the top stories
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
you